the world of football would be roughly
ten thousand percent more exciting if
they introduce more maps put some traps
and obstacles on the pitch enable
anti-gravity and make the beautiful game
even more beautiful at least that's what
rocket League is doing I'm Kate and is
your car ball news update rocket League
developers psionics has revealed a new
map it will be introducing to the rocket
labs playlist the map called pillars
will arrive in June and continues the
virtual reality themes the visual
aesthetic four pillars will continue its
tips hat towards virtual reality of the
studio said only this time with a
gameplay emphasis on using multiple
walls to your advantage these two walls
are the titular pillars and effectively
split the map into three lanes both
goals will remain in the center lane
however pillars will be available in the
rocket labs playlist for online and
offline exhibition play rocket labs made
its debut in February and was intended
to give players a casual competitive
environment and also allow players to
play prototype arena layouts on May
twenty-fourth rocket League was updated
to support cross play between xbox one
and pc this was a historic moment in
multiplayer gaming according to psionics
because rocket League became the first
xbox one game to allow cross play with
PC do you prefer your car ball to be
kept pure or are you happy to mix things
up a little let me know in the comments
will come and find me on Twitter I'm at
how not to draw thanks for watching and
fro your gaming and entertainment news
keep it gamespot
you